[Music]
what happens after death is there a
restful paradise in eternal torment a
rebirth or maybe just nothingness
well one Chinese Emperor thought that
whatever the hereafter was he better
bring an army we know that because in
1974 farmers digging a well near their
small village stumbled upon one of the
most important finds in archaeological
history vast underground chambers
surrounding that Emperor's tomb and
containing more than 8,000 life-size
clay Soldiers ready for battle the story
of the subterranean army begins with
yujeong who came to power as the king of
the Qin state at the age of 13 in 246
BCE ambitious and ruthless he would go
on to become Chuang D the first emperor
of China after uniting its seven warring
kingdoms his 36 year reign saw many
historic accomplishments including a
universal system of weights and measures
a single standardized writing script for
all of China and a defensive barrier
that would later come to be known as the
Great Wall but perhaps you sure Wong
dedicated so much effort to securing his
historical legacy because he was
obsessed with his mortality he spent his
last year's desperately employing
alchemists and deploying expeditions in
search of elixirs of life that would
help him achieved immortality and as
early as the first year of his reign he
began the construction of a massive
underground necropolis filled with
monuments artifacts and an army to
accompany him into the next world and
continue his rule this magnificent army
is still standing in precise battle
formation and is split across several
pits one contains a main force of six
thousand soldiers each weighing several
hundred pounds a second has more than
130 war chariots and over 600 horses and
1/3 houses the high command an empty
forth pit suggests that the grand
project could not be finished before the
Emperor's death in addition
nearby chambers contained figures of
musicians and acrobats workers and
government officials and various exotic
animals indicating that emperor teenth
had more plans for the afterlife than
simply waging war all the figurines are
sculpted from terracotta or baked earth
a type of reddish-brown clay to
construct them multiple workshops and
reportedly over seven hundred and twenty
thousand Labour's were commandeered by
the emperor including groups of artisans
who molded each body parts separately to
construct statues as individual as the
real Warriors and the Emperor's army
they stand according to rank and feature
different weapons and uniforms distinct
hairstyles and expressions and even
unique ears originally each warrior was
painted in bright colors but their
exposure to air caused the paint to dry
and flake leaving only the terracotta
base it is for this very reason that
another chamber less than a mile away
has not been excavated this is the
actual tomb of Qin Shi Huangdi reported
to contain palaces precious stones and
artifacts and even rivers of mercury
flowing through mountains of bronze but
until a way can be found to expose it
without damaging the treasures inside
the tomb remains sealed
Emperor Qin was not alone in wanting
company for his final destination
ancient Egyptian tombs contain claim
models representing the ideal afterlife
the dead of Japan's cohoon period were
buried with sculptures of horses and
houses and the graves of the jhana
Island off the Mexican coast are full of
ceramic figurines fortunately as
ruthless as he was emperor qin chose to
have servants and soldiers built for
this purpose rather than sacrificing
living ones to accompany him as had been
practiced in egypt west africa Anatolia
parts of North America and even China
during the previous Zhang and Jo
dynasties and today people travel from
all over the world to see these stoic
soldiers silently awaiting their battle
orders for centuries to come
[Music]